>> NBA BITS WE LOVE.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW, EVERYBODY.
WELCOME IN, WELCOME IN, FOLLOW
THOSE FINGERS REDDING, BECAUSE
WE'RE LOOKING FOR LOCKS.
LET ME INTRODUCE YOU GUYS TO THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE NEXT TO ME.
YOU GUYS MIGHT KNOW THEM
ALREADY.
MY NAME IS GREG IVORY.
NEXT TO ME IS THE MAN I LIKE TO
CALL MB.
YOU MIGHT KNOW HIM AS MICHAEL
BOLTON.
HE IS THE MAN OF THE HOUR.
AND THEN NEXT TO HIM IS --
>> SYAT.
>> PRODUCER.
>> ONE OF THESE DAYS, MAN.
AT LEAST YOU'RE NOT CALLING ME
THE RAT THIS TIME.
>> I DIDN'T MAKE THAT UP.
>> I KNOW YOU DIDN'T.
I KNOW YOU DIDN'T.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SAY, I TRIED
TO BAN BAGEL AND LOX FROM THE
SHOW BUT HE'S BACK IN HERE
CALLING ME THE RAT.
>> LAST WEEK WE DID A PARLAY AND
IT WAS RUINED BY YOU, RYAN.
[LAUGHTER]
TOOK OVER, AS ALWAYS.
PUT THE STIR YOUR WAY.
>> LET'S MAKE SURE WE TELL THE
PEEL THE RYAN PARLAY IS 0-1
OFFICIALLY.
OUR PARLAYS HAVE A DIFFERENT
RECORD.
>> THE SELF-PROCLAIMED MAN OF
THE PEOPLE PARLAY IS 0-1.
BUT WE ARE HERE.
WE'RE HERE TODAY.
WE'RE HERE TODAY, RYAN.
>> UH-HUH, YEAH.
>> SO DROP YOUR BEST BETS FOR
TONIGHT.
TNT GAMES, ROCKING WITH THE TNT
GAMES TODAY, CELTICS TAKING ON
THE NETS AND THE MAVERICKS
TAKING ON THE LAKERS.
RYAN?
HOP INTO THE CHAT.
WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT, BROTHER IN.
>> I HAVE TWO COMMENTS I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT HAPPENED BEFORE
THE SHOW STARTED.
B THOMPSON JUMPED IN HERE EARLY
AND SAID, YOU GUYS GOT TO TRUST
ME ON AT LEAST ONE LEG TONIGHT.
I'M ALWAYS MONEY, BUT Y'ALL
NEVER USE MY PLAYS.
LUCA8 PLUS ASSISTS.
I KNOW YOU ALL SCARED OF THE
RISK.
WE'RE NOT SCARED.
ALL RIGHT?
WE LIKE A LITTLE EASIER PLAY.
OTHERWISE, DO THE NINE ASSISTS.
AND THEN BEFORE I GET -- BEFORE
WE GET IN, DARIAN85 SAID WE NEED
A WINNER, Y'ALL.
TRYING TO TAKE MY LADY OUT TO A
NICE DINNER IF THAT'S NOT TOO
MUCH TO ASK FOR.
SAME.
EATING RAM HE KNOW.
>> NOT MUCH TO ASK FOR AT ALL.
I LOVE THE ENERGY THAT B
THOMPSON BRINGS.
>> YEAH.
>> I KIND OF LIKE THAT PLAY.
>> LET'S JUST JUMP RIGHT INTO
IT.
>> LUCA ASSIST?
I THINK HE CAN GET IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO I GOT SOME NOTES THIS WEEK,
BECAUSE I'M DEFINITELY TRYING TO
GET THIS BREAD.
>> YES, SIR.
>> HE HAS HIT OVER EIGHT AND A
HALF ASSISTS IN SEVEN OF HIS
LAST TEN GAMES, SO THAT'S PRETTY
GOOD NUMBERS.
I KNOW THAT GREG IS USUALLY THE
IN TUBS GUY, SO SORRY, I'M NOT
TRYING TO TAKE YOUR SHINE, HOME
I.
>> DO YOUR BRING, BROTHER.
>> I JUST WANT TO WIN SO BAD.
>> ME, TOO.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE
THESE STATS ON THE READY, BUT
THE THREE GAMES THAT NUMBER
DIDN'T HIT, DID IT AT LEAST
TOUCH EIGHT OR HOW MANY OF THOSE
WERE UNDER EIGHT?
>> I CAN GO BACK AND LOOK.
IT WAS ALWAYS PRETTY CLOSE,
THOUGH.
I MEAN, YOU GOT TO THINK, RIGHT,
THE LAKERS ARE A VERY BAD TEAM,
IN MY OPINION.
>> YES.
>> I THINK THEY'RE PLAYING
BETTER NOW, RECENTLY.
>> YEP.
>> BUT A LOT OF ONUS IS ON
LEBRON TO CARRY THEM.
AD IS NOT BACK.
THE ONLY THIS I THINK THAT I
THINK MAY RUIN THIS ONE IS IF IT
BECOMES A BLOWOUT, BUT I DON'T
REALLY SEE THAT HAPPENING
TONIGHT.
>> YEAH.
I AGREE.
I ALSO AGREE THAT THE LAKERS ARE
A VERY BAD TEAM.
THEY ARE THE WORST TEAM IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S SAYING
SOMETHING.
THE KINGS ARE IN CALIFORNIA.
>> LIKE THE BEAM, DON'T BE
DISRESPECTFUL, RYAN.
>> YOU KNOW WHO'S NEVER ON TNT?
SACRAMENTO KINGS, GREG.
NOBODY IS WATCHING.
>> THAT'S NOT MY TEAM.
THAT DOESN'T AFFECT ME AT ALL,
YOU KNOW?
>> I KNOW.
>> MY TEAM IS FREQUENTLY ON TNT.
>> YES.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
FREQUENTLY ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION.
>> HOW ON EARTH DID YOU COME
INTO THIS SHOW JUST LOCKED AND
LOADED ON SACRAMENTO AGAIN?
I DON'T GET IT.
>> IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY.
SOMEBODY IS GOING TO NEED TO
TAKE THE HEAT.
IT'S SACRAMENTO TODAY AGAIN OF
THAT'S IT.
>> HEY, WE GOT TO SEND YOU TO
SACRAMENTO ONE OF THESE DAYS.
>> YEAH, WELL, THERE WON'T BE
MUCH TO LOOK AT WHEN I GET
THERE.
>> ARE WE LOCKING IN LUCA?
WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA,
WHOA.
RYAN --
>> ALL RIGHT?
>> TO ME, .5?
IT JUST DID YOU WANT MAKE SENSE,
LIKE, TO ME.
.5 IS LIKE DRASTIC AS FAR AS
NOT.
>> MY ONLY TAKE ON THIS, AGAIN,
IS AVOIDING A BAT B.
IF HE FINISHES WITH EIGHT, WE
GOT IT AT EIGHT.
AND IT'S 2:30.
LIKE 2:30 ISN'T BAD IF WE JUMP
AND TAKE SOMETHING ELSE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> THE ONLY REASON WHY I AGREE
WITH YOU RIGHT NOW, RYAN,
BECAUSE I KNOW WHERE GREG IS
COMING FROM, IS THAT THIS IS OUR
FIRST LEG.
SO WE'VE GOT TO SEE WHAT ELSE WE
PICK, AND I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
BE IN A GOOD SPOT.
BUT IF WE PICK MORE CONSERVATIVE
LEGS, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO USE
THAT HOOK TONIGHT.
>> OKAY.
AL RIGHT.
YES.
LET'S GET BACK IN HERE.
I GOT A TIP FROM MEGALITO11 IN
THE CHAT EARLIER IN THE DAY WHO
TOLD ME THAT THE CELTICS ON NO
REST THIS SEASON, BEAT THEIR
OPPONENTS BY AN AVERAGE OF 12
AND A HALF POINTS.
>> WOW.
>> AND JASON TATUM AVERAGES 36.8
POINTS IN THOSE GAMES.
SO I SAY LET'S GET BACK OVER TO
TO THE CELTICS AND NETS GAME.
>> WHAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO,
FELLAS AND LADIES, EVERYONE IN
THE CHAT, IS WE ARE NOT BETTING
ON JALEN BROWN AT ALL.
HE'S QUESTIONABLE.
AND EVEN IF HE PLAYED, I DON'T
WANT TO BET HIM FOR THE REST OF
THE YEAR, BECAUSE THAT MAN BE
SELLING.
HE'S LIKE THAT MAN.
HE'S THE WORST.
>> HE BOILED HIS LAST GAME.
HE GOT LIKE 40 OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
41.
>> HE DID.
HE ALSO WASN'T ONE OF THE ONES
WHO DIDN'T CASH FOR US LAST
TIME.
IT WAS LUCA THAT TOLD AND JASON
TATUM THAT SOLD.
BUT WE'RE BACK ON THE TATUM
TRAIN.
>> NO.
YOU'RE BACK ON THE TATUM TRAIN,
RYAN.
WE DIDN'T SAY NICK ABOUT JASON
TATUM.
YOU DECIDED TO GO TO THE GAME.
YOU DECIDED TO CLICK OVER TO THE
BOSTON CELTICS AND BROOKLYN
NETS.
YOU DIDN'T EACH READ A COMMENT.
>> WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
>>
>> NO.
NO.
I GOT TO FINISH THIS.
YOU BROUGHT UP A COMMENT.
>> IT WAS SENT TO ME EARLIER IN
THE DAY.
>> YOU BROUGHT IN THE COMMENT
THAT WAS SENT TO YOU EARLIER IN
THE DAY.
YOU ALREADY KNEW WHAT YOU WERE
GOING TO COME AND DO WITH THIS.
>> GREG, DID YOU SEE THE
COMMENT?
>> IT WAS SENT EARLIER IN THE
DAY.
IT WASN'T IN THE CHAT.
I GOT MY LITTLE PEOPLE WHO SAY,
HEY, YOU SHOULD PUSH THIS
PROBLEM AN GRAND AN TONIGHT.
>> EXACTLY.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT YOU CAME
IN HERE AND DID.
YOU PUSHED THE PROPAGANDA FROM
PREVIOUS -- WE GOT PEOPLE
FILLING UP THE CHAT WITH TAKES.
WE GOT VIN 70 3.5%.
I DON'T KNOW IF I WANT TO ROCK
WITH THAT.
>> NOT A TNT GAME.
>> WE GOT A LOT OF MORE PEOPLE
IN HERE TALKING ABOUT OTHER
THINGS THAN WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT, RYAN.
>> YEAH.
WELL, THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
JAMES HARDEN ASSISTS, JOE LMB
POINTS, AND I DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY TIMES I GOT TO SAY WE'VE
GOT A WHOLE GRAPHIC UP HERE THAT
SAYS ONLY TNT GAMES.
I DON'T WANT TO YELL AT THE
CHAT.
>> SOMETIMES YOU GOT TO YELL AT
IT.
>> TYREE, OVER 26 POINTS.
>> THIS IS WHERE THINGS GO BAD,
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT DJ MARRY
SAYING SHOWING NO LOVE TO THE
REAL COMMENT SECTION.
SHAKING MY HEAD.
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
RYAN COMES IN HERE WITH HIS
PROPAGANDA AND TAKES OVER AND WE
LOSE EVERY PARLAY BECAUSE RYAN
WANTS TO TAKE OVER.
WE'RE NOT DOING THAT TODAY, NO.
>> IT WAS A SUGGESTION.
LOOK AT GREG MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
RYAN, THE PEOPLE DECIDE WHO IS A
MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
MAN, BEN SIMMONS, TRIPLE DOUBLE.
SEE?
LOOK IT.
I'M JUST KIDDING.
HAS TO BE A NO FROM ME.
>> BUT IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, RYAN,
SERIOUSLY, I SEEN THIS COMMENT
LAST WEEK.
>> OKAY.
>> I SEEN THIS COMMENT THE WEEK
BEFORE.
AND WE NEVER, EVER TALK ABOUT
IT.
CHRISTIAN WOOD, OVER 20 POINTS.
>> OKAY.
BUT TO BE FAIR, WHEN THEY
DROPPED THE CHRISTIAN WOOD PROP
LAST WEEK, IT DIDN'T HIT.
IT DIDN'T COME CLOSE.
AM I CORRECT?
>> YOUR PARLAY DIDN'T HIT,
EITHER.
>> I KNOW.
I KNOW.
BUT YOU'RE BRINGING UP TWO
THINGS THAT DIDN'T HIT:  MY
PARLAY, WHICH WAS THE CHATS
PARLAY, AND THIS.
>> FIRST OF ALL, YOUR PARLAY
GO AHEAD.
>> WE GOT TO LET THE PEOPLE
DICTATE.
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
>> WE'VE GOT RYAN THE RAT IN
THIS CHAT AGAIN.
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
>> RYAN, WE GOT TO LET THE
PEOPLE DECIDE.
KYREE25 POINTS, MY BOY B
THOMPSON SAID IT.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT IT.
>> LISTEN, B. THOMPSON, I TO
TAKE YOUR LEGS.
YOU WON'T FIND SOMEBODY WHO IS
MORE  ANTI-KYREE THAN ME.
AND HE DOESN'T PLAY WELL AGAINST
BOSTON.
JUST IN HIS OWN HEAD.  THE ONLY
TIME HE PLAYED WELL AGAINST
BOSTON WAS GAME ONE AT THE
GARDEN THIS PAST YEAR.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WHAT ABOUT ENVELOP ARA D. RILEY
SAYS THOMAS BRYANT, TEN BOARDS.
>> THOMAS BRYANT?
THAT'S A LOT FOR HIM.
WE CAN GO OVER TO IT.
>> YOU GUYS ARE FIGURING THAT
OUT, BUT I JUST GOT TO SHOUT OUT
MY MAN KSX STEELERS X, FIRST
TIME VIEWING AND THESE GUYS HAVE
ME ROAMING.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
WELCOME.
>> WELCOME TO THE SHOW, BROTHER.
WE LOVE IT.
>> WELCOME.
>> LET'S SEE.
WE'VE GOT A RYAN THE RAT BURNER
WITH A PICTURE OF ME THAT SAYS
I'M A RAT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> LISTEN, THIS IS CRAZY,
BECAUSE THERE'S MORE RATS IN
THIS CHAT THAN THERE ARE IN NEW
YORK CITY AND THAT'S SAYING A
LOT, MAN.
THIS IS PRETTY BAD FOR YOU,
RYAN.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
I WILL TAKE KING OF THE RAT.
I'LL BE KING OF THE RATS.
FORGET ABOUT MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
KING OF THE RATS, THAT'S ME.
>> DO IT.
JUST OWN IT.
THOMAS BRYANT, THOMAS BRYANT,
WEREN'T WE TALKING ABOUT HIM?
>> YEAH.
>> THE ORIGINAL PLAY WAS TEN
BOARDS.
LISTEN, HE HAS KIND OF BEEN
PRETTY IMPORTANT FOR THAT TEAM,
I THINK, RECENTLY, ESPECIALLY
WITH ND OUT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HIS NUMBER IS
SET AT.
NINE, TEN SEEMS LIKE A LOT, BUT
I DON'T KNOW, YOU'RE IN A GAME
AGAINST THE MAVS WHO SHOOT A LOT
OF THREES.
THAT COULD BE A LOT OF LONG
REBOUNDS AND HE'S A LONG
REBOUNDER.
MAYBE IT'S WORTH A PLAY.
DOES THAT SAY NINE AND A HALF?
>> YEAH, NINE AND A HALF.
>> WHAT ABOUT HIS POINTS?
I FEEL LIKE THEY'VE BEEN DISHING
HIM THE BALL.
HE'S BEEN SCORING.
>> HE'S A SCORER.
16 AND A HALF.
THAT'S HIGH.
>> COULD WE DO 15?
>> I'M COOL WITH IT.
>> AND I'M ABOUT TO GO PULL UP
HIS RECENT NUMBERS JUST SO IT
MAKES SENSE.
AND RYAN, I JUST WANTED TO LET
YOU KNOW THE 15 PLUS, FOR THE
PEOPLE.
I'M TRYING TO SHOW YOU THE WAY.
>> IT GETS SAID TO ME, GREG.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO TELL YOU.
>> YEAH, BUT THAT WAS BEFORE THE
SHOW.
>> OH, SO THE PLAYS BEFORE THE
SHOW DON'T COUNT?
>> YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A WHOLE
AUDIENCE RIGHT HERE.
WE HAVE A WHOLE AUDIENCE THAT
ARE, LIKE, TRYING TO TAP INTO
THE SHOW, YOU KNOW?
AND YOU'RE A PRODUCER.
YOU KNOW.
OUR OBJECTIVE IS TO BE
INTERACTIVE WITH THE AUDIENCE
THAT ARE HERE.
>> OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
I'M NOT SAYING THE GUY IS NOT
HERE NOW.
I'M JUST SAYING IT GOT SENT TO
ME EARLIER.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO DARIAN85 IN THE
CHAT IS SAYING THAT'S TOO HIGH.
>> 15, TOO HIGH.
>> I'M GOING TO AGREE, SIMPLY
FOR THIS REASON.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS.
THE ORIGINAL PLAY THAT WAS SENT
IN WAS REBOUNDS.
I AGREE THAT HE HAS BEEN SCORING
A LOT, SO I'M NOT SURE THAT IT'S
TOO HIGH, BUT THE PLAY WAS
REBOUNDS ORIGINALLY.
>> CAN I JUST READ HIS POINTS
TOTAL?
IN, LIKE, THE LAST TEN GAMES IN.
>> TEN PLUS.
>> 17, 29, 19, 21, 18, 19.
15 POINTS?
>> SO TEN PLUS IS A LOCK THEN?
>> OH, TEN PLUS IS AN ABSOLUTE
LOCK.
>> ALL RIGHT.
I THINK WE'RE GOOD.
LET'S ROCK.
>> IS THAT EASY?
>> I LOVE IT.
IF YOU LIKE T I LOVE IT.
>> AND LET'S REMEMBER NOW, WE DO
LIKE THE 15TH, BUT WE DO LOVE
THE 10TH.
SO IF WE GET SHORT ODDS, WE
COULD BUMP THAT UP.
>> YEAH.
GOOD CALL, MB.
THAT'S A GOOD CALL.
I MEAN, HIS REBOUND NUMBERS ARE
PRETTY GOOD, TOO, GUYS.
I'M JUST SAYING.
YOU GUYS ARE TALKING --
>> WE GOING TO MAKE THIS THE
THOMAS BROWN PARLAY?
BECAUSE I DON'T HATE IT.
>> I DON'T HATE IT EITHER.
>> I'M JUST SAYING --
>> ALSO, LET ME BE CLEAR ABOUT
ONE THING.
WE DISCUSSED THIS BEFORE THE
SHOW.
SO FOR THE CHAT THAT'S LISTENING
RIGHT NOW, I WANT TO GET TO THE
SECOND GAME SO BAD.
SO IF WE ONLY HAVE ONE PLAY FROM
THE FIRST GAME, I WILL NOT BE
MAD ABOUT IT.
>> HEY, RYAN --
>> ALSO, THERE'S LIKE SIX NEW
BERN ERA COUNTS.
SO NO ONE -- BURNER ACCOUNTS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU'RE DOING
THIS.
WE'VE GOT RATTY RYAN.
>> KING RAT.
>> KING RAT ONE.
WE HAVE RYAN, KING OF RATS.
THIS IS ACTUALLY REMARKABLE.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> AND THERE ARE PICTURES OF ME
FROM THIS SHOW, IN THIS SHIRT.
>> QUAMERE COOK SAID RYAN
SPLINTER.
IF YOU'RE A TEENAGE MUTANT NINJA
TURTLES' FAN YOU SHOULD GET
THAT.
JAQUAN SAYS JUST CHECK THE
PLAYS.
IT SEEMS SIMPLE.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO BE THE KING
OF THE RATS, DO WHAT THE CHAT
SAYS.
>> RIGHT.
IT'S THAT EASY.
>> HEY, RYAN, I GOT A QUESTION
ON.
>> WHAT'S UP, MAN?
>> CAN WE PARLAY THE THOMAS
BRYAN DOUBLE DOUBLE OR NOT?
>> I DON'T THINK WE CAN DO
COMBOS.
AS THE MAN OF THE PEOPLE, I WILL
CHECK.
>> YOU KEEP PUSHING THAT UP.
>> NO, WE CAN'T.
WE CAN'T.
>> WE CAN'T IN.
>> NO.
>> I LIKE THIS, THOUGH.
I LIKE THIS.
>> YES.
I WILL SAY WE MAY NEED TO
STRETCH THE BOUNDARIES OF WHAT
WE DO IN THE NEXT CELTICS GAME,
JUST BECAUSE WE NEED JUICE.
>> BUT RYAN, TIMEOUT, TIMEOUT.
>> TIMEOUT GRANTED.
30 SECONDS.
>> WE HAVEN'T SEEN A WIN IN A
WHILE RIGHT?
I MEAN, NOT A WHILE I DON'T WANT
TO SAY THAT.
LIKE WE WIN.
WE WIN IN OUR OWN WAYS.
BUT, YOU KNOW, YOU TOOK OVER
THESE PAR LAYS AND WE HAVEN'T
SEEN A WIN IN A MINUTE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> I CAN'T.
WE WIN IN OUR OWN WAYS.
>> ALSO PUSH THIS PROPAGANDA OF
A LOT OF JUICE.
>> PROPAGANDA?
>> WHAT IF WE, LIKE, DIDN'T,
LIKE, GO FOR SO MUCH JUICE THIS
TIME AND ACTUALLY JUST WENT FOR
A WIN?
>> MAYBE WE JUST NEED TO SEE ONE
GO THROUGH THE HOOP.
THAT'S ALL.
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
IF WE'RE DOUBLING PEOPLE'S
MONEY, THEN IT'S LIKE YOU CAN'T
BE MAD AT THAT.
IT'S A WIN.
>> CAN I JUST -- I'M REALLY
TRYING TO BE ACTIVE IN THE CHAT
RIGHT NOW, BUT EVERY TIME I LOOK
DOWN, I SEE RYAN'S NEW AVATAR
FOR THE BURNERS POP UP LIKE IT'S
TYPING, BUT I DON'T SEE YOU
TYPING.
>> THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S NOT ME.
>> I KNOW IT'S NOT, AND THAT'S
REALLY REMARKABLE THAT YOU HAVE
FIVE BURNER ACCOUNTS THAT ARE
ALL COOKING AT THE SAME TIME.
>> AND THEY'RE NEW PICTURES OF
ME.
THE DATES STRESSED LOOK IS
LITERALLY RIGHT THERE.
>> THAT'S SO FUNNY.
THAT'S THE SAME SHIRT YOU'VE GOT
ON.
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO
SAY.
IT'S FROM THIS SHOW.
>> OH, THAT'S SO FUNNY.
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
COME ON.
WE WERE COOKING.
HOLD ON.
>> NO, I THINK.
I WILL SAY THIS.
THIS IS LIKE WHEN YOU KILL,
LIKE, A PREGNANT SPIDER AND THEN
JUST, LIKE, ALL OF THE BABY
SPIDERS COME OUT?
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT NOW
IN THE CHAT.
>> OH, MY GOD.
WE NEED MORE PIGS.
B THOMPSON ASKS ABOUT KYREE'S
THREES.
WE NEED TO MOVE ON TO THE OTHER
GAME.
GO AHEAD.
>> I WAS JUST GOING TO SAY,
LET'S WIN TODAY.
LET'S WIN.
GO TO KYREE'S THREES.
>> THREE AND A HALF.
>> THAT'S TOO MANY.
>> GO TO TWO.
LIKE WHAT'S ONE?  WHAT'S ONE?
>> ONE?
MINUS 8,000 IN.
>> IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
>> IT BROUGHT THE ODDS DOWN.
>> IT DID BRING THE ODDS DOWN.
>> I DON'T LIKE THAT.
I DON'T KNOW IF I LIKE THAT.
>> YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT KYREE
PLAYING THE CELTICS.
>> YEAH.
AND HE DOESN'T PLAY WELL.
HEY, GO TO YOUR BOY.
GO TO YOUR BOY, RYAN.
GO TO YOUR BOY, JASON TATUM.
>> I DON'T WANT TO DO THREES.
LET'S DO POINTS.
I THINK JASON TATUM GOES OFF.
>> LISTEN, IF WE WANT JUICE OR
IF WE WANT TO WIN, HERE'S THE
DIFFERENCE.
HERE'S THE DIFFERENCE.
>> IS HE LITERALLY JUST WALKED
YOU TO THIS AND YOU ARE GOING
THROUGH THE DOOR.
HE WALKED YOU TO THE DOOR AND
NOW YOU'RE ABOUT TO WALK THROUGH
THE DOOR.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I LIKE THE DOOR THAT WE'RE
ABOUT TO WALK THROUGH.
THAT'S IT.
I'M NOT KNOCKING.
I'M OPENING THE DOOR.
I LIKE OVER 31 AND A HALF.
I COULD BE TALKED INTO TEASING
IT DOWN TO 25 AND A HALF.
I COULD BE TALKED INTO -- I
DON'T WANT TO TEASE DOWN TO 30.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO GO OVER
31.
I COULD ALSO BE TALKED INTO 35
PLUS.
>> COULD YOU BE TALKED INTO
ROBERT WILLIAMS APPLE HE OTHER
BOUNDS?
HE'S STARTING TONIGHT AFTER A
GAME OF REST.
>> A FAN DID COMMENT THAT.
BUT RYAN --
>> YES, I COULD.
SAUCE 90, JAY SUM TATUM, 25 AND
A HALF.
>> 25, PLUS JASON TATUM.
>> 25 PLUS?
>> YEAH.
>> DARIAN ASKS, IS TATUM/BROWN
PLAYING?
IT'S BACK TO BACK.
JALEN BROWN IS QUESTIONABLE.
HE MAY PLAY.
HE ALSO MAY NOT PLAY.
JASON TATUM, AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED, IS PLAYING.
>> HE WILL PLAY, UNLESS
SOMETHING GOOFY HAPPENS RIGHT
BEFORE THE GAME.
I SEE THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
TATUM TO REALLY SHOW WHAT HE'S
GOT.
I DON'T KNOW IF I'M GOING TO USE
LEGACY GAME THE WAY YOU DO.
>> I USE IT AS A LOOSE TERM.
>> IT'S VERY INTERESTING,
BECAUSE I BELIEVE A LOT OF THE
CONVERSATION AROUND HIM AND
BEING THE MVP HAS KIND OF
QUIETED DOWN A LITTLE BIT, BUT
HE'S STILL PLAYING REALLY WELL.
SO MAYBE THIS IS A NIGHT WHERE
HE GOES OFF WHEN HIS RUNNINGMATE
IS NOT PLAYING.
>> YES.
>> HEY, RYAN IF.
WHAT'S UP, MAN IN.
>> I WANT TO TAKE A STEP INTO
YOUR PLAYBOOK AND TAKE OVER.
>> GO AHEAD, MAN.
LET'S COOK.
>> ROBERT WILLIAMS SIX PLUS,
JASON TATUM 25 PLUS.
GIVE ME THOSE ODDS.
>> OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
SIX PLUS.
GEEZ.
THIS IS GOING TO BE BRUTAL,
GREG.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE BRUTAL.
>> I THINK IT'S GOING TO WIN.
>> PLUS 187.
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> WHY?
WHY?
LET ME ASK THE CHAT.
J2 COOL SAYS TATUM 35 PLUS.
WHAT IF WE DO THAT?
LET'S JUST ENTERTAIN IT FOR ONE
SECOND.
LOOK AT RATTY RYAN SAYING LET'S
RIDE.
LET'S RIDE.
NEVER MIND.
WHAT IS IT?  WHAT'S THE ODDS?
IS IT PLUS FOUR OR 93?
>> IF WE GO TO TATUM 35 PLUS.
IF WE DO LUCA, EIGHT PLUS
ASSIST, THOMAS BRYANT, TEN PLUS
POINTS, THOMAS BRYANT EIGHT PLUS
REBOUNDS, THOMAS BRYANT, LIKES
THE GAME, ROBERT WILLIAMS, SIX
PLUS REBOUNDS AND JASON TATUM,
35 PLUS POINTS, IT GETS US THE
PLUS 493.
>> I TRUST YOU.
I TRUST YOU.
>> WAIT A SEC, MAN.
35 POINTS IS TOO MANY POINTS,
MAN.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> YEAH.
I AGREE.
>> HONESTLY, HONESTLY, I LIKE
JASON TATUM.
I THINK HE'S REALLY GOOD.
I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED ON
EITHER SIDE OF THIS GAME IF ONE
OF THESE TEAMS GETS BLOWN OUT TO
WANT.
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
SITTING FOR THE CELTICS.
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
THAT JASON TATUM IS GOING TO
SCORE ALL THE POINTS.
HE SHOOTS TERRIBLY, THEY MIGHT
GET BEAT BY 15.
SO 35 JUST SEEMS A LITTLE TOO
MUCH.
>> FLY MAN SAID HE'S GOIN
LET'S RIDE.
GO TO 25 AND LET'S RIDE.
>> I LIKE THE 25 IF WE START TO
NEGOTIATE THIS THOMAS BRYANT
LEGACY GAME AND BEEN PUTTING IN
WILL HE DROP.
HE'S FIVE POINTS AWAY FROM A
MILESTONE, AND YOU KNOW THAT
CORNY ASS LEBRON KNOWS HE'S THAT
CLOSE.
>> ON NATIONAL TELEVISION.
>> I LIKE THE WAY YOU THINK, MB.
I LIKE THE WAY YOU THINK.
>> OKAY.
YEAH.
LISTEN, WE HAVE, LIKE, THE
SKELETON OF THIS PARLAY.
I'M DOWN TO NEGOTIATE.
DJ MOREY SAYS RYAN HAS TO HAVE A
LONG SHOT AND A PARLAY TO FEEL
GOOD.
WE JUST NEED THE ODDS UP.
>> Y'ALL CAN'T DO TO ME WHAT CAL
DO TO RYAN, MAN.
>> WHY, WHAT HAPPENED?
>> IT'S LEVELS.
YOU BELIEVE WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> DON'T START THAT.
>> RYAN --
>> WAIT THIS, PARLAY IS AT PLUS
506 KNOW.
WE STILL DON'T LIKE IT?
>> WE GOT TO MOVE JASON TATUM
DOWN A LITTLE BIT.
>> WHAT ABOUT 30?
>> ZERO MAYBE.
>> I DON'T HATE THAT.
LET'S GO CHECK ON LEBRON.
>> WE'LL DO 25.
ARE WE KEEPING ROBERT WILLIAMS
AT SIX?
>> LIKE THAT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S MOVE OVER.
>> THIS LOW KEY IS FEELING LIKE
A SIX LEG PARLAY.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU GUYS.
>> YEAH, IT IS.
IT IS FEELING THAT WAY.
>> I'M STARTING TO FEEL LIKE THE
FIVE, STARTING TO DO A SIX.
BECAUSE I LIKE ALL THE LEGS WE
GOT.
I REALLY DO.
>> DO BROWN 30 PLUS.
>> I WAS JUST THINKING THE SAME
THING, MAN.
>> PLAY IT SAFE.
>> I LIKE SOMETHING.
>> NO, NO, THAT'S ENOUGH.
336, IS IT SIX LEGS OR FIVE LEGS
IN.
>> IT'S SIX.
>> SIX LEGS.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> REMEMBER, WE HAVE SOMETHING
IN THE BACK POCKET.
WE HAVE THOMAS BRYANT, 15 POINTS
AND NOT TEN.
>> OR --
>> OH, YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
>> WE HAVE LUCA.
>> LUCA WHAT?
>> I LIKE THE THOMAS BRYANT LEG
BETTER.
>> THAN -- OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
>> SO RYAN, YOU WERE SAYING GO
LUCA EIGHT AND A HALF?
LET'S DO THAT.
>> IT'S UP TO YOU GUYS.
ALSO, HOLD ON.
LET'S GO CHAT HERE.
WOULD WE PREFER THOMAS BRYANT 15
PLUS POINTS RATHER THAN TEN PLUS
POINTS IF WE CAN GET THE PARLAY
ON THE SCREEN IN ITS CURRENT
ITERATION, OR LUCA OVER EIGHT
AND A HALF ASSISTS RATHER THAN
EIGHT PLUS ASSISTS?
>> SO THERE'S A COMMENT IN HERE,
KELLY BEAN IS SAYING MAKE IT
EIGHT SINCE RYAN IS TALKING
ABOUT SPIDERS.
THAT A PRETTY -- I LIKE THAT
VIBE.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> MAKE IT EIGHT LEGS?
>> NO, NO.
[LAUGHTER]
I WAS TALKING ABOUT THE EIGHT
ASSISTS VERSUS EIGHT AND A HALF.
>> OKAY.
>> IF YOU WANT TO MAKE IT --
KELLY, IF YOU WANT US TO MAKE IT
AN EIGHT LEGGED PARLAY, JUST SAY
THE WORD AND WE'LL DO IT.
>> DON'T MAKE THOSE PROMISES.
>> B THOMPSON SAID THOMAS 15
POINTS.
>> SO DID JAQUAN.
>> MAKE IT 15 PLUS.
>> B THOMPSON, B THOMPSON, CAN
WE MAKE THIS YOUR PLAY?
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU SAY YOU CAME
IN HERE AND YOU SAY, NO, NO, NO.
JUST THE THOMAS BRYAN.
YOU COME IN HERE AND YOU DON'T
TAKE MY PICKS.
THOMAS BRYAN, I'M WILLING TO
GIVE TO YOU AS YOUR PICK.
>> I SEE A LOT OF SUPPORT AT 15
FOR BRYANT.
>> 15.
>> SO THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE
CURRENTLY.
WE HAVE LUCA DONSICH, EIGHT PLUS
ASSISTS, THOMAS BRYANT, EIGHT
PLUS POINTS.
JAY SOME TATUM, 25 PLUS POINTS.
I WOULD ALSO BE WILLING TO MOVE
THOMAS BRYANT TO THE 15 PLUS.
>> LET'S DO IT.
LET'S SEE WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
480.
AGAIN.
>> CALL IT A DAY.
>> THAT'S BETTER.
>> CALL IT A PARLAY.
>> I WAS WRONG, INDEED.
KELLY BEAN IS CHECKING ME AND
SAYING SPIDER PARLAY.
GIVE ME EIGHT LEGS.
I'M KIDDING.
>> YEAH.
>> THIS ONE FEELS GOOD.
THIS ONE FEELS GOOD.
I DON'T KNOW, WHY DO YOU HAVE
THAT FACE?
>> IT'S JUST IT FEELS LIKE WHY
ARE WE DOING -- LIKE I DON'T
KNOW.
SIX LEGS IS A LOT.
LIKE WE JUST -- WE CAME ONTO THE
SHOW AND WE WERE STRUGGLING TO
HIT, SO LET'S HIT SOMETHING.
NOW I FEEL LIKE WE HAVE SIX LEGS
JUST TO HAVE SIX LEGS WHEN WE
COULD HAVE JUST BEEN RIDING
JASON TATUM 35 PLUS POINTS ALL
ALONG.
>> DIDN'T WE DO 30?
>> WE DO 25.
>> THAT'S COOL.
>> I LIKE IT.
>> IT'S GOOD.
ALL RIGHT.
WELL, LOOK AT THIS.
TAKE OUT WILLIAMS' RYE BOUNDS
AND PUT JASON TATUM 30 POINTS
AND SEE WHERE WE'RE AT.
SEE IN HE DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
>> IS THAT GOING TO DO MUCH FOR
US?
>> WHAT ARE YOU TRYING TO DO?
>> GET US TO AT LEAST 500.
>> THAT IS THE PROBLEM.
THAT IS THE PROBLEM.
>> WHY?
>> YOU'RE GETTING GREEDY.
>> YOU'RE TRYING TO FORCE IT.
YOU'RE FORCING IT AND EVERY WEEK
YOU FORCE IT AND THEN --
>> THIS SOUNDS LIKE PENT UP
FRUSTRATION FROM YOU, GREG.
>> IT DOES.
I WANT TO WIN.
>> YOU'RE ACTING LIKE I DON'T
WANT TO WIN.
>> YOU'RE FORCING PLUS 500 WHEN
YOU DON'T NEED TO.
WE HAD TO LOCK THAT PLUS 300,
PLUS 330.
>> NO, I LIKE THIS.
>> SEE?
BECAUSE IT'S PLUS 500.
>> IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT IS WHY I LIKE IT, YES.
>> IS PRINCE IN THE CHAT SAYING
A WIN IS A WIN.
I GOT TO GO WITH THE PEOPLE AND
GREG TONIGHT, MAN.
WE'VE DONE YOUR PARLAY THE LAST
THREE WEEKS, MAN.
IF IT'S PLUS 480 FOR SIX LEGS,
IT DOESN'T MATTER, BECAUSE THE
MONEY IS GOING TO CASH AND WE'RE
GOING TO -- AND MY MAN DARIAN IS
GOING TO GET A CHANCE TO TAKE
HIS LADY TO DINNER.
YOU WANT TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
HIM NOT TAKING HIS LADY TO
DINNER?
I DON'T WANT TO LIVE WITH THAT
ON MY CONSCIENCE.
>> NO, I DON'T.
I DON'T WANT TO BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THAT.
I ALSO SAID I WOULD LIKE TO DO
THE SAME THING.
>> HEY, RYAN?
>> YEAH, WHAT'S UP?
>> I'M SORRY.
I DIDN'T MEAN TO CONSULT YOU
OFF.
I WAS JUST GOING TO READ A
COMMENT FROM THE PEOPLE.
>> GO AHEAD.
I WAS JUST GOING TO RECAP THE
PARLAY.
ROCK, PAPER, SCISSORS?
>> BAN KID 019 SAYS THAT'S HOW
YOU LOSE BETTING, TO GET
SPECIFIC ODDS.
THE PEOPLE.
AND YOU'RE MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
>> KING OF THE RATS ACTUALLY,
PLEASE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOU GOT TO LISTEN TO THE
PEOPLE.
>> I AM LISTENING TO THE PEOPLE.
>> SO MAKE IT PLUS 480 AGAIN SO
WE CAN GET OUT OF HERE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO LIKE IF YOU'RE LISTENING TO
THE PEOPLE, TAKE LUCA DOWN THE
SIX --
>> NO, NO.
>> BY THE WAY, ALSO, SO THIS IS
A FIVE LEG PARLAY.
WE HAVE FOUR LEGS.
SO HERE IT IS.
WE HAVE FOUR LEGS IN THE SAME
GAME.
WE HAVE LUCA EIGHT PLUS ASSISTS,
THOMAS BRYANT EIGHT PLUS
REBOUNDS, WILL HE DROP 30 PLUS
POINTS.
THOMAS BRYANT 15 PLUS POINTS.
AND JASON TATUM 30 PLUS POINTS.
THAT'S ALSO MY OTHER THING HERE.
>> HERE GOES RYAN.
>> I JUST LIKE THE FOUR LEGS IN
THE SAME GAME.
>> HERE YOU GO.
>> FOUR LEGS MATTER.
>> IT'S IN THE SAME GAME.
>> WHO CARES?
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
WHO CARES?
[LAUGHTER]
>> OKAY.
CHAT.
THIS IS -- ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL SCROLL THROUGH AGAIN.
>> WAIT.
WHAT IF WE TAKE OUT WASN'T IT
SIX LEGS?
>> LUCA --
>> RIGHT.
WE TOOK OUT --
>> WE TOOK OUT ROBERT WILLIAMS.
>> WHAT?
>> WE HAD SIX REBOUNDS.
THAT'S A LOT.
>> THAT IS A LOT.
>> BUT HE DIDN'T DO ANYTHING FOR
US.
IT WAS LIKE MINUS 3,000.
>> RYAN, I DON'T THINK YOU
UNDERSTAND, MAN.
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING, BRO.
WHAT?
AND ROBERT WILLIAMS IS MADE OF
GLASS.
I DON'T THINK YOU GUYS
UNDERSTAND.
WE WOULD BE LUCKY IF HE FINISHED
THIS GAME.
>> HE JUST RESTED FOR A WHOLE
GAME.
>> THAT DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING.
>> OH, MY GOD.
GREG, I DON'T WANT YOU TO HAVE
TO TELL THEM TO PUT RYAN'S
PARLAY ON HERE AGAIN.
>> OKAY.
>> I FEEL LIKE THIS IS WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> IS THAT WHAT -- COME ON, MAN.
THIS IS HAPPENING WEEK AFTER
WEEK, RYAN.
>> ON WOULD THIS MAKE YOU GUYS
FEEL BETTER IF WE DID IT THIS
WAY?
IF WE ADDED ROBERT WILLIAMS?
>> WE'RE GOING TO TAKE TATUM
BACK DOWN TO 25, LIKE WE SAID.
>> TELL 'EM, MB.
>> AND CAN WE DO THAT, PLEASE?
BECAUSE I'LL FEEL A LOT BETTER.
>> THANK YOU, RYAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THERE WE GO.
BOOM.
PLUS 480.
LET'S GO GET THIS CASH, MAN.
>> WHAT IS IT? WHAT'S THE BET?
WHAT'S THE BET?
>> LET'S DO THIS.
>> DO YOU HEAR THE DEPRESSION IN
HIS VOICE?
HERE COMES A THREE, TWO, ONE.
>> WE HAVE LUCA DONSCICH, EIGHT
PLUS ASSISTS.
THOMAS BRYANT, EIGHT PLUS
REBOUNDS.
LEBRONS JAMES, 30 PLUS POINTS.
THOMAS BRYANT, LEGACY GAME,
APPARENTLY, 15 PLUSES POINTS.
ROBERT WILLIAMS, IS SIX PLUS
REBOUNDS.
JASON TATUM, 25 PLUS POINTS.
THAT IS SIX LEGS.
>> YEAH, I LIKE THAT.
>> PLUS 480.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO LIE, THOUGH.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIE.
>> DON'T LIE.
>> TAKE LUCA ASSIST TO SIX.
>> WHY?
>> NO.
WE'RE NOT DOING THAT.
>> EIGHT AND A HALF?
THE ONLY REASON WHY WE'RE NOT
DOING THAT IS BECAUSE WE'VE GOT
THE FIRST COMMENT BEFORE THE
SHOW EVEN STARTED.
>> OH, THAT'S TRUE.
>> HE GIVES US EIGHT.
>> THAT'S B. THOMPSON.
THAT'S TRUE.
THAT'S B. THOMPSON'S LEG.
DARIAN SAYS I NEED SOME MILK.
I'VE HIT MY DAIRY LIMIT.
>> I WISH I WAS BY THE FRIDGE.
I WOULD HAVE GOT YOU SOME.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I'M GOOD WITH THIS.
ASK THE CHAT.
CHAT, THUMBS UP?
THUMBS DOWN?
IF WE'RE GOOD WITH THE SIX LEG
PARLAY AT PLUS 480.
I LOVE IT.
>> DOUBLE O SAYS LEBRON IS NOT
DROPPING 30 TONIGHT IN ALL CAPS.
JUST JUMPED TO PLUS AN # 530.
WHAT MOVED?
THOMAS BRYANT, OF COURSE, AND
LEBRON.
ALL RIGHT.
AND THOMAS BRYANT AGAIN.
>> IS GUYS, I'LL TAKE THE LEBRON
LEG AS MY LEG AND I DON'T CARE,
BECAUSE HE IS LITERALLY JUST --
HE'S JUST WATCHING FOR THIS
RECORD THAT HE'S GOING TO BREAK.
I SWEAR IT.
AND HE KNOWS THAT IF HE HAS 35
TONIGHT, HE'S GOING TO GET ALL
OF HIS FOLLOWERS AND THEY'RE
GOING TO LOSE BY 15.
IT'S PERFECT.
I'VE ALREADY WATCHED IT HAPPEN.
>> YOU'VE SEEN --
>> THE ONLY THING THAT, LIKE,
HAS ME SECOND-GUESSING OR
THINKING IN THIS PARLAY IS
LUCA'S ASSIST.
I FEEL LIKE PERSONALLY, HE'S
MORE DEPENDENT AS FAR AS IN A
REBOUNDER THAN THROWING ASSISTS,
BECAUSE, LIKE, HE SCORES A LOT.
WE KNOW HE'S GOING TO REBOUND.
>> YEAH.
BIG ON LOCKS AND SIX PLUS
REBOUNDS.
SORRY.
THE SNAKE SAID SIX PLUS
REBOUNDS.
>> OH, SNAKE VERSUS RAT.
WE NEED TO DIAL THAT UP.
>> YEAH.
>> L BAY ALSO SAYS LUCA
REBOUNDS.
I DON'T WANT YOU TO THINK I'M
PUSHING ANY PROPAGANDA, BRYAN.
>> THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
YOU AND I.
I DON'T ACCUSE YOU OF PUSHING
PROPAGANDA.
I LISTEN.
I ABSORB.
I'M LIKE A SPONGE, GREG.
I TAKE EVERYTHING.
I TAKE THE HATE.
I TAKE THE SLANDER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WE LOVE YOU, BRO.
WE LOVE YOU.
>> I WOULDN'T WANT TO DO THIS
SHOW WITH ANYBODY ELSE.
>> IS AWE, I LOVE YOU, TOO.
SIX PLUS.
>> SPONGE OF LOCKS, SOMEBODY
SAID A SPONGE OF LOCKS.
SO FUNNY.
SIX PLUS REBOUNDS IN.
>> NO.
>> MINUS 1050?
>> GUYS, WHAT ARE WE DOING?
THIS IS VEN LEG PARLAY.
>> WE'RE CLOSE TO KELLY'S EIGHT
LEG SPIDER PARLAY.
>> TAKE OFF THE ASSISTS.
TAKE OFF THE ASSISTS.
>> TAKE THE ASSISTS OFF.
>> WATCH, WATCH, WATCH.
>> WHY NOT?
I JUST WANT TO SEE --
>> IT'S PLUS 416.
>> NOT FOR SIX LEGS.
NOT FOR SIX LEGS.
I LIKE WHAT WE HAD BEFORE.
>> WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
480 AND 416? YH.
WAIT.
HOLD ON.
WHAT'S HIS -- I DON'T LIKE THAT.
WAIT, HIS ASSIST JUMPED TO NINE
AND A HALF?
THAT'S GOOD FOR US.
>> YEAH.
SO LET'S LEAVE IT AT EIGHT
BEFORE WE MOVED THAT SHIT -- I
JUST SWORE.
I'M ABOUT TO GET FIRED.
>> IS YOU CAN CURSE ON HERE.
>> YEAH, YOU CAN.
>> I'M JUST FIRED UP, MAN.
I'M TRYING TO WIN AND I THINK
THE EIGHT IS THE LOCK.
>> YEAH.
I THINK SO, TOO.
I LIKE WHAT WE HAVE.
DO WE WANT TO RECAP IT ONE MORE
TIME AND, AGAIN, FINAL CALL OR
THUMBS UP OR THUMBS DOWN?
YEAH, YEAH.
>> OH, YEAH.
LET'S GO.
>> THOMAS BRYANT, MAN, IS GOING
TO -- THE 15- PLUS IS GOING TO
--
>> NO, NO.
THIS LUCA EIGHT ASSISTS IS
REALLY GOING TO SIT WITH ME.
>> EIGHT ASSISTS?
SO WE DON'T FEEL GOOD.
>> WHAT IF YOU MOVED BRYANT DOWN
TO TEN NOW THAT IT'S PLUS 534?
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> THIS IS SCARY.
I DON'T KNOW.
THERE IS A BIG -- GOSH, GOSH.
>> WHAT HAPPENED?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
>> YEAH.
WE FEEL -- IT SEEMS LIKE WE FEEL
SIGNIFICANTLY WORSE ABOUT THIS.
>> NO.
I DON'T NECESSARILY.
I JUST DON'T KNOW WHY THE ODDS
MOVED SO MUCH.
I'M COOL WITH THE THOMAS BRYANT
--
>> 15.
ME, TOO.
>> THE LUCA STUFF MOVED IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION FOR US.
I'M COOL WITH LUCA.
AND ALSO, THAT WAS THE ONE, WE
OB THOMPSON ONE.
>> B THOMPSON, DO YOU LIKE THAT
LUCA PLAY OR DO YOU LIKE ANOTHER
ONE?
COMMENT IF YOU LIKE ANOTHER ONE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I'M DOWN TO KEEP IT, BUT IF
YOU LIKE ANYTHING ELSE, YOU JUST
LET US KNOW.
>> OH, HE JUST SAID WHEN LUCA
EIGHT ASSISTS HIT AND YOU ALL
DON'T TAKE T I'LL PERSONALLY HIT
YOU UP.
WE'VE GOT TO RIDEITH IT.
>> DARIAN 85, 15 POINTS FOR
THOMAS BRYANT ISCARY.
WE'VE GOT KYREE2 PLUS AND THREE
IN HIS HERE.
THE KYREE, WE LOOK AT KYREE AND
THE THOMAS FOR TEN POINTS IS NOT
GOOD.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
WHAT IF WE HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION ON THOMAS BRYANT RIGHT
NOW?
>> DO WE JUST TAKE HIS
OVER/UNDER, WHICH I BELIEVE,
WHAT IS IT?
11 AND A HALF OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT IN.
>> OKAY.
WAIT.
OKAY.
YOU GUYS ARE NOT GOING TO LOVE
THIS.
WHAT IF WE TAKE -- WHAT IF WE
TAKE THE THOMAS BRYANT POINTS
OUT AND WE BUMP TATUM TO 30
PLUS?
>> DON'T HATE THAT.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> NOPE, GREG, THIS IS IT.
>> THANK YOU, BULLY.
>> I DON'T HATE THAT.
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE JUST WATCH.
>> IT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE THE
NUMBER THAT MUCH, G.
>> YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT WINNING,
RYAN.
YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT.
>> DON'T YOU SAY THAT.
DON'T YOU PUT THAT ON ME.
THAT IS NOT TRUE.
>> YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT WINNING.
YOU DON'T.
YOU HAVEN'T SHOWED THAT.
YOU JUST CARE ABOUT GOING OVER
500, PLUS 500.
>> NO.
I'LL COOL WITH THIS.
IF WE WANT TO SETTLE ON PLUS 461
WITH THESE FIVE, THAT IS WHAT I
WILL DO.
I'M COOL WITH THIS.
LET'S TAKE OUT THOMAS -- HEY,
LET'S GET THOMAS BRYANT TEN
POINTS OUT OF THERE.
LET'S NOT DO THAT.
I DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
>> THOMAS BRYANT, WHAT'S HIS,
LIVE, OVER UNDER?
BECAUSE I'M SEEING A LOT OF
BRYANT 11 AND A HALF POINTS.
>> YEAH.
16 AND A HALF.
IT WAS 16 AND A HALF.
>> OH, WOW.
OKAY, YEAH.
NO.
WE'RE GOOD ON THAT.
>> WELL, WHAT DID YOU GUYS FOUND
OUT?
>> I DON'T DISLIKE JASON TATUM
TO GO OVER 30 POINTS, BUT IT
PROVES MY POINT.
IT'S RYAN PUSHING HIS PROPAGANDA
ON OUR PARLAY.
>> WE HAVE TO TAKE THE POWER
FROM YOU AT LEAST ONE
WHATEVER.
>> HEY, YOU GUYS WANT TO SCROLL
FAN DUAL --
>> NEXT SHOW, LET ME SCROLL FAN
DUAL.
>> WE'RE IN TROUBLE.
>> BECAUSE MAN, I DON'T KNOW.
>> IRAN SAYS GREG, LET HIM KNOW
WE NEED WINNERS ONLY.
>> COME ON, MAN.
THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO WIN.
I'M TRYING TO WIN, RYAN.
I'M TRYING TO WIN.
>> RYAN, SORRY.
I'M NORMALLY THE MIDDLEMAN AND
I'M THE DEVIL'S ADVOCATE, BUT IT
SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO GO BACK TO 25 POINTS AND
WE'RE JUST GOING TO HAVE TO RIDE
WITH THE ORIGINAL.
I THINK THAT'S THE WAY.
>> HEY, LOOK IT.
>> WHY?
>> TURN IT INTO RYAN'S PARLAY,
EYE ROLLS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> OH, GOD.
>> JAQUAN SAYS RYAN IS PISSING
ME OFF.
JAQUAN, WHAT DO YOU WANT?
LIKE WHAT DO YOU WANT, THOUGH
IN.
>> WE TOLD YOU WHAT WE WANTED,
RYAN.
WE HAD IT.
>> YOU WANT THE THOMAS BRYANT
POINTS BACK?
>> YES.
THE PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY SAID IT.
>> SO WE'RE DOING A SIX LEG
PARLAY?
>> YEAH.
>> IS OH, GOD.
>> "LOVE HOW UPSET YOU GET.
IT'S REALLY FUNNY.
BAGEL AND LOX SAYS ROYCE O'NEAL,
25 BUCKS PLUS, PLEASE.
NOW WE'RE GETTING TO THE
TROLLING PART.
CHAT NOW.
>> DID THIS -- OKAY.
BIG MEACH, THIS GUY RYAN MAKES
YOU LOSE.
PLACE THE DAMN PARLAY NOW AND
CALL IT A DAY.
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
I'VE TAKEN ENOUGH HEAT HERE.
I'LL CONCEDE.
15 PLUS?
>> YEAH, 15.
>> OKAY.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> YEP, YEP, YEP, YEP.
>> THERE IT IS.
LET'S ROLL.
>> WHEN THIS HITS, I'M GOING TO
LOSE IT.
I'M GOING TO LOSE IT WHEN THIS
HITS.
SOMEBODY SAID, OVL ROSE SAYS IF
THIS TURNS INTO THE RYAN PARLAY,
I'M NOT TAILING.
>> BEING ON.
GUESS WHAT?
IT'S NOT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> OB ROSE, RYAN LOST US MONEY
LAST WEEK.
>> AND DARIAN 85 SAYS GUESS ME
AND MY LADY EATING AT AT AT AT
WENDY'S FOR DINNER.
>> NO, BRO, WE'LL GET YOU RIGHT.
RYAN DIDN'T HAVE MUCH TO SAY ON
THIS ONE.
>> AND THAT'S THE DETERMINING
FACTOR FOR YOU?
>> I MEAN, THE LAST THREE WEEKS,
YOU KNOW.
>> WHAT THE PEOPLE ARE SAYING IS
THEY HAVE MORE FAITH IN THOMAS
BRYANT THAN THEY DO IN PRODUCER
RYAN.
IT'S TOUGH.
>> I'VE NEVER BEEN MORE
DISRESPECTED ON THE SHOW BEFORE,
I WILL SAY THAT.
>> BUT WAIT, WAIT.
>> IT'S ALL LOVE.
>> CAN YOU READ THE PARLAY ONE
MORE TIME AND THEN JUST KNOW
THAT WHEN THIS HITS, THE CHAT IS
GOING TO BE ON FIRE NEXT WEEK.
I JUST CAN'T WAIT TO SEE IT.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S DO THIS.
IT'S THOMAS BRYANT EIGHT PLUS
REBOUNDS.
LEBRON JAMES, 30 PLUS POINTS.
LUCA DONSCHICH, EIGHT PLUS
ASSISTS.
THOMAS BRYANT, LEGACY GAME, 15
PLUS POINTS.
ROBERT WILLIAMS, SIX PLUS
REBOUNDS.
AND JASON TATUM, 25 PLUS POINTS.
PLUS 546.
SIX LEGS THIS TIME, NOT FIVE.
SIX.
>> I SEE CHECK MARKS BY B
THOMPSON.
HE'S IN FAVOR.
AND REMEMBER, YOU'RE PUTTING
THIS IN ON FAN DUAL.
YOU'RE GETTING YOUR MONEY BACK
IF IT LOSES, BUT IT WILL NOT,
BECAUSE RYAN HAD NO SAY IN IT
THE END OF THE PARLAY.
SO WE'RE ALL GOING TO EAT.
>> WE'RE GOOD.
I FEEL GOOD ABOUT THIS ONE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I HAVE NO WORDS.
>> I FEEL GOOD ABOUT THIS ONE.
RYAN?
>> WHAT, MAN?
>> YOU ALREADY READ THE PARLAY.
READ IT ONE MORE TIME FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T GET IT.
>> JUST FOR YOUR ENTERTAINMENT,
GREG.
>> THEY'RE JUST TROLLING.
HE COULDN'T READ THE PARLAY,
BECAUSE HE HAD NO SAY IN IT.
>> I'LL DO IT ONE MORE TIME JUST
FOR YOU, GREG.
WHY NOT?
LUCA, EIGHT PLUS ASSISTS.
THOMAS BRYANT, EIGHT PLUS
REBOUNDS.
THOMAS BRYANT, 15 PLUS POINTS.
JASON TATUM, 25 PLUSES POINTS.
LEBRON JAMES, 30 PLUS POINTS.
ROBERT WILLIAMS, SIX PLUS
REBOUNDS, PLUS 546.
THE CHAT'S PARLAY.
THE CHAT.
IT'S ALL OVER.
NINE CHAT WAS ALL OVER THIS ONE
TODAY.
>> RYAN, YOU'RE GOING TO SLEEP
SO MUCH BETTER TONIGHT KNOWING
THAT YOU HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
THIS EITHER WAY.
SO I FEEL LIKE THIS IS A WIN/WIN
FOR YOU.
>> IT IS.
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
BUT I DON'T KNOW.
I HAVE A LOT OF AMMO NOW.
THERE'S A LOT OF BLAME THAT I
CAN PASS.
I WOULD NEVER, BECAUSE GREG, YOU
KNOW THIS.
I'M NOT AN I TOLD YOU SO GUY.
>> IS YOU'RE A BIG ONE, BIG I
TOLD YOU SO GUY.
WHAT'S YOUR RECORD ON THE SHOW?
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN IT'S A
RECORD?
IT'S A PARLAY.
THERE WAS NO RECORD.
>> NO, NO, NO.
YOU DIDN'T GET THE JOKE.
IT'S OKAY.
WE'LL MOVE ON.
IF YOU GUYS WANT TO TAILOR A
FIVE LEG PARLAY, HEAD OVER TO
FAN DUAL AND TO WANT INTO THE
TNT THURSDAY'S NO SWEAT PARLAY
FOR A FREE BET IF IT LOSES.
WE'RE NOT GREAT AT ANY BETS
TODAY.
WE'RE ABOUT TO GET UP OUT OF
HERE.
RYAN, THEY TOLD ME TO HAVE YOU
READ THE PARLAY ONE MORE TIME,
BUT I'M NOT GOING TO DO THAT TO
YOU.
NOT GOING TO DO THAT TO YOU.
>> THE PEOPLE IN THE CONTROL
ROOM ARE CLOWNING ME JUST AS
MUCH AS YOU GUYS, BY THE WAY, ON
A DAILY BASIS.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT.
>> THEY TOLD ME TO HAVE YOU READ
THE PARLAY, BUT YOU GUYS SEE THE
PARLAY RIGHT THERE.
RYAN DID NOT HAVE MUCH SAY SO IN
THIS PARLAY, SO WE ARE IN GOOD
HANDS, PEOPLE.
WE ARE IN GOOD HANDS.
MB, LET'S GET ON UP OUT OF HERE,
RYAN AND MB.
MY NAME IS GREG IVY.
NEXT TO ME IS MB.
I CALL HIM MB.
YOU GUYS MIGHT KNOW HIM AS
MICHAEL BOLEN.
I HAVE TO MAKE THAT CLEAR.
ELSE THE MAN OF THE HOUR.
AND NEXT TO HIM IS THE MAN WE
ALL LOVE.
RYAN, WE LOVE YOU, BRO.
PRODUCER RYAN, A/K/A, KING OF
THE RATS.
>> KING OF THE RATS.
>> A/K/A A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
>> HEY, WE'RE UP OUT OF HERE,
Y'ALL.
PEACE.